what's going on everybody welcome to the
very first QA or questioning answers
video I get a lot of the exact same
questions over and over and over so I
thought I could make these Q&A videos to
kind of answer them all at once for
people also so I can point people to
them so the first question that I'm
going to answer here and then also as I
answer these questions the first ones
are just ones that I've personally found
but as we go on if you want you can ask
questions in the comments and the next
time I make one of these videos I'll try
to answer at least mostly those
questions the questions that are asked
in the comments so the first question I
usually get is how did you learn Python
and not only how did you learn but how
do you learn Python nowadays like
because I get a lot of requests for like
book recommendations and stuff like this
so first of all a little bit about me I
have been self-employed since I was 12
years old I have had part-time jobs
along the way my last job was as a
waiter and that place ended up going out
of business at the time I was working
like two days a week or something just
for some side cash by that point I
already had my own businesses and I was
making almost enough money to survive I
just didn't want to quit my job but
eventually that place actually went out
of business and then from that point on
I just worked for myself so so I'd
always been self-employed but I paid a
programmer to make websites for me and
do the things that I need I want it done
but eventually I came up with the idea
for what is now sent Dexcom which is
sentiment analysis for stocks and other
things and the web developer I had at
the time was not going to be doing
natural language processing they had no
interest in it they couldn't do it so I
decided I'll do it myself and so I found
that Python had the module or library
called n ltk which the natural language
toolkit an NL TK dot org slash book is a
great book for learning how to use NL TK
and it has kind of an introduction that
is an introduction to Python even so
that actually served as my intro to
Python was that n ltk book basically so
a perfect introduction for me a probably
horrible introduction for most people
but that's why I usually tell people
like you want to get off the basics as
soon as possible and actually start
working on something that interests you
because
the basics are boring the basics aren't
applicable really directly immediately
to anything that you might be interested
in so in most cases you can you can
usually just like learn the true basics
like if statements and variables and
functions and that kind of stuff once
you learn that stuff like get out and
like do something because that's how
you're actually gonna learn anyway
that's how I learn Python nowadays I
really just kind of Google everything so
I don't actually I don't have any formal
computer science or mathematics or
anything background but I just use
Google I just look it up and Google has
information on anything you could
possibly want but especially programming
the programmer community is incredibly
willing to share things so that brings
us to the second question maybe even
this ones the more common question I get
and that is what do you do for a living
so what I do for a living is I run I've
always just run online businesses that's
just kind of always been my forte lately
it's been most of my like base income
comes from Python program at net in the
YouTube channel just from like add
revenue
I can relatively comfortably estimate
how much money I'm gonna make on the
YouTube channel and Python programming
at net so I make money from advertising
and then on Python program at net from
the subscribers with plus equals one so
I make a okay base salary at least
enough to like pay the bills right and
then beyond that I get contracting and
consulting jobs so if someone comes at
comes to me and has something that
sounds interesting or something
I'll take those on but for the most part
I really enjoy working on Python
programming net and a lot of people ask
me like why do you do that why don't you
just like why don't you go start a
business as if like going first of all
as if Python print net isn't a business
but also as if it's like really simple
to just go and start start a business
and be a billionaire or something it's
really not that easy and also as someone
who likes spent much of my life starting
businesses and running online businesses
it's actually really difficult to find
something that you you're good at you
actually enjoy doing and you get some
sort of like reward for
that isn't monetary as well so with the
YouTube channel
I get like pretty much everything plus
more so like with the YouTube channel
first of all I get to learn new things
constantly if I wasn't doing the YouTube
channel in Python programming that net I
would not be anywhere near the
programmer that I am today so if I
wasn't doing that I wouldn't have
learned all these things myself and
because one of the best ways to really
like learn something is to teach it and
if you try to teach something that you
don't really know it quickly like first
of all it solidifies what you do now and
it shines a light on what you don't know
and if you're oblivious to something
that you didn't know eventually
someone's gonna watch that video and
comment and tell you that you're stupid
right and so that happens and thanks to
some of those sometimes jerk viewers but
sometimes like they're just they're good
people they give you information you
actually learn just from the fact that
you shared and that's why I like peer
review is often thought of as like a
really a good thing to do it can be
painful because sometimes people are
really mean but at the same time if you
do peer review of code and stuff like
that it will make you a better
programmer over time so for me I just I
get to learn new things I get to like
focus on whatever I want to focus on I
get to learn new things over time I get
to help people and for the most part
like 99.9% of the people I interact with
in regards to Python programming net are
like super positive and and like
pleasant people to be around
as opposed to other businesses that I've
run so for example with sent XCOM it's a
cool business I really like the data
analysis aspect to it it's a lot of fun
to like dive into that that kind of big
data but at the same time at the end of
the day to make money what I have to do
is sell that data to either institutions
or individuals themselves and that can
be kind of a challenge so with
institutions you're usually dealing with
like finance firm types of people and I
don't mean to like offend anybody really
but the people in the world of finance
like too many of those people are betas
who either think they're alphas or think
that they need to act like
to fit in because that's what you're
supposed to do because they've seen like
movies or something like that so those
people are just not fun to deal with and
then also there was a lot of people that
as they're like interested in buying the
data I just know when speaking to them
that they're not gonna get anything from
the data like they're not going they
don't know how to properly make use of
the data and I'm not here to teach you
how to use the data I'm just here to
sell you the data that you want access
to so I don't know it just was not it
wasn't fulfilling to me like I made
money doing it but it just wasn't
fulfilling and I actually still have
like I have sources that still take the
data like if you're on
quanto peon for example you can get the
date you can get access to the data for
like twenty dollars a month or something
so it's at least super cheap and it's
easy to play around and there's like a
free stream of it too so you can figure
out if it's actually going to be worth
it to you so that's just kind of like
worked out but to get back to the point
of like business like running a business
is first of all most businesses will
just fail but if you can find a business
that you like you really enjoy doing and
you have a passion for it and you make
money at it and you're good at it
and you're helping people at the same
time it just seems like well let's hold
on to that in the meantime you know we
can look for other things but I just I
get so much value back from Python
programming at net that that's why I do
it I just really really like doing it
and also in terms of recommendations
that I have for people a lot of people
ask me like when they're asking on the
topic of how do you learn Python and
stuff don't forget that one of the ways
that I'm learning Python and improving
myself is by teaching Python so I
usually suggest to people that you
should do the same you should have like
a blog or maybe even a YouTube channel
like try to do that because that'll also
get you exposure so the other thing not
only do I get contracting and consulting
offers I get job offers like every week
I get multiple job offers and usually
they're like two smaller companies and
stuff but in the last couple months I've
had an offer from Apple and Facebook and
probably those are the two like biggest
companies that you would even know about
but many other companies beyond that and
I'm not reaching out to these come
like I'm not even applying they're
coming to me and they're finding me and
so you can pretty much do the same or
you can reach out if you have something
to show them that like I hey what I've
been doing that's what they want to see
and if you look at like what Google
applications want or Facebook or
whatever they want a portfolio look
that's what they actually want to see
nine times out of ten they care about
like your the other stuff on your resume
but for the most part they want to see
what what you do and what you actually
know anyway that will wrap up with the
first Q&A hopefully that was slightly
enlightening to some of you as I said
before if you have questions that you
want me to answer just comment below and
I'll answer them I still have quite a
few other questions that I get like all
the time that I'm going to answer but
these first two or at least the second
one took me a long time to get through
so I'm gonna cut it off here anyway
questions below and otherwise I will see
you in the next tutorial or question and
answer video who knows